el departamento de justicia revela que
entre el 2016 y el 2020 la policía
recuperó casi 24 mil armas fantasmas en
los lugares del crimen alrededor de eeuu
un problema que empezó a preocupar a las
autoridades después de que seis personas
murieran en santa mónica california tras
ser baleadas por un hombre con un arma
fantasma estas armas no tienen número de
identificación porque son ensambladas
por partes que se compran separadamente
en el mercado sin embargo hoy yo bardem
desde la casa blanca dijo que en 120
días los distribuidores de estas armas
tendrán que empezar a ponerle el número
de identificación no solamente a ésta
sino también a las partes principales de
estas armas antes de poderlas vender
esto permitirá si entonces a las
autoridades rastrear las armas que son
encontradas o confiscadas en las escenas
del crimen sin embargo organizaciones
como gun owners of america prometió ya
que lucharía inmediatamente contra el
decreto y que demandar a la oficina de
armas explosivos tabaco y alcohol de
estados para detener la implementación
de esta media